now under protest is chick rekt yeah do
we need any other intro
no let's just do it dread yes get it
over with it do you need this fanfare
for chipwrecked you just have like a
cran drawing your 20th century is
shipwreck you live with it cuz you man
they're just like they won't get that
runtime out as quickly as possible yeah
we know you all go home parents you know
what I see in Fight Club when they're
talking about inserting a giant fucking
cod when the cartoon dog and the snooty
cat with the celebrity voices are all
singing and dancing that's when you see
it giant cock like I feel like this was
the movie he was talking about literally
there is no plot it's like we're on a
cruise ship but not even going to give
you the pretext of giving a shit
[Music]
I'm calling it right now I've never seen
this movie
that's David Cross yeah I don't see it
either we both have the same idea I hope
so cuz that was legit scary okay
those kids dancing looks so
disinterested like this is tape 30 that
is that is some real white kid dancing
we got going out there this is like how
adam sandler chooses his movies based on
vacations it's like you know I always
want gonna cruise let's just shoot a
chipmunk movie oh my god it's like song
3 what the hell we have a contract we
need 12 songs on the soundtrack we got
Ben as many women as possible the CG
really does get worse and worse how's
that tie is that's like Roger Rabbit
shit right yeah it's like a cartoon tie
they're putting on Eddie valiant yet now
it would have been hilarious we just
came out the cartoon tux I just assumed
Jason Lee was computer-generated
throughout the whole film and seriously
kids
Simon wear something more than blue
Alvin wear something more than red
Theodore just pick a yellow I don't care
it's close to green why that sounds like
Anna Faris fed up I can tell cuz I know
what her voice fed up sounds like I'm so
glad they picked her for this part
that's cuphead I rather would watch that
movie yeah I feel like it would probably
star the rock at least Corey I'm kind of
horrid and I'm just a slut how bad is
your life when you need to show up
rodents like how vapid are you it just
ends with the chip heads running up the
girls skirts annoying there wow this
movie was only 10 minutes I'm impressed
even under the costume David Cross is
very funny there that's what this movie
feels like to me hot gravy spilled
directly on my balls
and put a shot why are you watching
jungle monster four come with a more fun
title than that come on wait a minute
that knife would like chase eyes out of
his pocket into Dave's handle I got
bigger and bigger from different angles
ah fuck it's a lot yeah yeah only one
movie captures the true tedium of
shuffleboard and that is album in the
chipper we put the music on shuffle and
we're bored
in hindsight I'm a really awful parent
like this happens a lot in the event of
an emergency Jason Lee can be used as a
flotation device he actually rents
himself out as what not filming Chipman
his voice is a great builder I just want
to see them talking like and then
there's just Tom Hanks shut up Christ
Nick jumps into the water any faster oh
yeah that's clearly the same water kitty
pool you know what time in the studio
snoop ran out of matches
got a place going with just two carrot
sticks I get it cuz he's a STONER and he
can make that was a noble effort
are there no predators on this island
that can eat them please God
well that was needed it's one of the
racist tribes from Gilligan's Island
it's gonna shut up god yeah like you
know eight-eight or nine um years nine
years and you still have all your teeth
super clean your clothes are clean you
look like you just stepped out of a
hotel that's gotta be on our joke cuz
there's no way she could be there eight
nine years that she would look like that
she's from a mental ward that's on the
island would it be funnier slash even
kind of cooler if she was like Jane or
something like giant sphere and she's
covered in mud and stuff like that she's
like chasing him down is that like what
would that be funnier she's actually an
enemy know being in the jungle without
any like you you're close with last nine
years
totally not not a rip not a fucking rift
yeah why does that anger me that no cuz
I'm seeing the comedic potential of what
they could do with this if she can have
the stupid little house and everything
that's fine but you gotta make her like
a jungle queen or something they
wouldn't bother that literally would
require using an extra brain cells
everybody looks like the jungle and that
like the hotel's right behind on the
other side of the camera
well she created that path by living
there for nine years yeah really you
have a moon and rats and you can't make
them do that Joe Wow stupid as a bird in
this giant nest all the content that is
the weirdest fucking thing
[Music]
except for the moon he sees Tim carry
space kills them all I don't even know
what they're doing like who is that
supposed to be we know what the typical
you get Beth I'm gonna go drive over
some crazy
what is Simone yeah I just don't get
what it is I don't get it help me
understand I'll give him credit they did
go five minutes without a song for this
film that was impressive so if if he
takes her clothes off would he be
deflowering her deflowering her better
than the jokes events maybe uh there are
no Chipmunks this woman is out of the
stylist she just imagined these other
chipmunk movies this has been her story
all around
oh yeah and she's actually just like in
a pile yeah it's like great with a
firefly she's dirt this is what she sees
before she dies Gaby quiet they're
shooting George of the jungle three next
door there's little Theodore Dave I
barely cared about what you had to say
about the first two can't imagine the
big-boned one is gonna be any more
interesting I want Dave across in a bird
suit like in every bad movie we ever
watched David Cross needs his own review
okay the cross in a purse and the best
part is they don't even know what they
found which means that the rest of the
treasure is mine oh my god are we really
doing this I'm crazy but also a treasure
hunter you know that when Simon's in
driving me crazy
what's right I think they're into both
and the only reason they did is because
I'm a monster but cruel inhuman monster
who feels no emotion no sympathy no
regrets I just enjoy inflicting pain
Dada do you think there is like a dial
coach like we need to make sure this
ship mundo there was no coach for
anything that would just be aware as a
real French person like I need to make
sure it's a chipmunks ad enemas accent I
am seriously gonna go old okie dokie
literature club by the time is and I'm
just gonna start stabbing myself enter
like a Zen place no you're not leaving
me you're gonna face this with a my
Apple watch just told me time to breathe
I can't be seeing that happen not since
Moulin Rouge and I've been so invested
in a jukebox musical this guy changed
pretty fence wowwwww the color change
very fast ska help me we found something
it's a raft with three human skeletons
and six tiny rodent like skeletons in
their mouths Wow
[Music]
where's Project David crossover work
done huh
I'm Jerry Springer and here's my final
thought fuck this movie and everybody
who was involved but god bless oh I'm
good with that
fight I got nothing
hey we're done
you